[Music]  when we are talking about due diligence  we mean companies taking concrete  steps throughout the entire supply chain  so to ensure responsible business  conduct  by identifying and mitigating negative  human rights  social and labor rights and  environmental  impacts  what we're fighting for is clear  mandatory rules  for companies to look at the risks that  they're taking when it comes to people  and planet  i think the clearest example is the  example of rana plaza where  a few years ago a factory collapsed with  a lot of deaths as a result and there  were a number of european companies who  were having clothes  made over there in a situation that  under this new law  should not be possible  so we are in the middle of a health  crisis and we are in the middle of the  climate crisis  and we need these tools in place as soon  as possible  to make sure that we are all taking  responsibility and we are all making  sure  people and planet are safer and  healthier